at first glance darvid olivera's artwork
looks almost like sketches drawn in air
but the sculptures are actually made of
wire suspended in space the portuguese
sculptor has already won several awards
he began experimenting with wire
straight out of art school I searched a
line that could go outside the paper I
was a big fan of drawing so I connected
sculpture and wire assumed the most
interesting material to be able to join
both his work is part of a group
exhibition on view at the carpe diem
Center for Contemporary Art in Lisbon
through December the historic palace in
the centre of the city
isn't just an exhibition space and for
Oliveira it was also a source of
inspiration and so is the Tagus River
which he calls an important source of
strength his apartment doubles as a
studio Oliveira does his research here
and designs for sculptures along with
wire he also uses cloth plastic and
small objects he makes his sculptures by
hand using simple tools he also wants to
use as few natural resources as possible
which is why he uses a minimum of
material to make a line that surrounds
the surface that's in my mind and I just
go for it it doesn't have doesn't have
to be a direct process but usually is I
don't go for the drawing in 2d
olivera's work has also been attracting
attention outside portugal in 2013 one
of his sculptures starred in a Japanese
marketing spot his art teeters between
sculpture and drawing that's also why it
was shown at the casa de cerca outside
Lisbon which is devoted only to drawing
he has a sculptures mind but sculpture
for him is something that he does with a
drawing process so he works with wire as
if he were drawing on on air this game
with perspective is something that
fascinates many artists one is French
artist Bell nappa whose work only comes
alive when viewed from the correct angle
that's also the idea behind German
Street artist Edgar Munez work who's
known for his 3d illusionist sidewalk
paintings Tim Noble and sue Webster
create works from scraps and rubbish to
cast shadow sculptures the sense of the
unexpected is part of the fascination I
think that's a way to get people
attention just for them to realize if
they look a bit closer and closer they
will get some other things today David
olivera's works sell for up to 6,000
euros a piece many have been exhibited
internationally above all he wants his
art to spark a dialogue I would like to
see my art in public spaces for it would
be accessible to everyone one of the
characteristics of this work was the
idea of children a public that is not as
used to art or an art space
in his current show David Olivera
focuses his delicate wire sketches on
creatures from the deep blue sea